The Joe Rogan experience who knew who Michael Keaton was when beetle juice came
out.
He was a comic and he was on a television show before that. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
Michael Keith was on a sitcom. I'm trying to think of what it was. Mr.
Something, right? Hmm. Mr. Big, is that a thing?
God it. I don't remember. But it was a sitcom working, working.
What was it about stiffs working stiffs?
He also did a little, uh, Tony Randall show.
Tony Randall just pop up as this.
Um, he was a standup. He was on evening at the improv.
Yeah, his is, he's got a big neon at the comedy store.
All's fair. In the Mary Tyler Moore hour. It says.
Yeah, he was around for awhile. And you know,
there's a lot of people that really reluctant to accept him as
Batman. Hilarious. This is kinda like this thin guy. He doesn't,
it's not jacked. Might've been the best Batman.
Without a doubt. Might've been the best Batman. No question about it.
That's including Christian bale. Yeah. Not only was he the best Batman.
He was also the best. Bruce Wayne believable glasses.
Tip of his nose researching.
Stupid fake voice though. There he is. Oh, Batman.
Fake voice. Did you see the founder is.
Being considered for a Batman role? There's a.
TV. I think he was going to be on the TV show.
What was he going to be like Batman? There's like a TV show. Uh,
the flag here is going to pop up in the flash, I think is wired.
Wow. He's in, he is in talks to play Batman. That's crazy.
It was in the summer. They talked about it.
You're using an ad blocker champion.
Ah, backup.
Slash um, who was the worst? Batman to the least believable Clooney.
Ben Affleck. Yeah.
Ben Affleck. Affleck. Nah. Well, yeah. Okay. Both of them.
I think Aflac has to take it, but I don't even know.
Athletes doing it still. That's the problem. Really? Yeah.
They're doing a new movie now. Netflix, Batman again, the justice league.
He's been Affleck. He's not Batman. He's been Affleck.
I don't not like Ben Affleck. I like Ben Affleck, but that's bad.
That's not bad.
We'll have the, uh, guy from, uh, Twilight is going to be him too.
Oh yes. Pattinson. Yeah. Yeah. Again, that's the guy from Twilight. Oh,
that's not Batman.
Because taking a Michael Keaton spot and the flash.
So like a month later they announced Affleck's going to be him. So who knows?
They need a new guy. He needed a new guy. Who's jacked.
Right?
Me after I get on testosterone, you're going to need a few years.
I could be Robin. Now though.
Could do the original one.
It's so funny because the bat there was like the Batman comic books that were
very 1950s. Right. That, that sort of style.
And then there was, uh, the Batman, um,
those illustrated books. What do they call those graphic novels?
The graphic novels are very different because then the graphic novels novels,
it was very dark and very like really cool,
really well drawn and like heavy duty, like different Batman,
like Batman was jacked. And you know, there's like a lot of like serious, um,
storylines and a lot of heavy duty.
Now that was the Batman that sort of existed in th that was
the dark night. That was, uh, like the Christian bale, Batman.
That kind of made sense. But the original Batman for TV was ridiculous.
Look at him like, look how he's dressed to get that. It looks everything.
Jeremiah. After the weight gain challenge.
The dude looked like he never worked out. He had this ridiculous belt on,
he had silly shorts on the Cape.
Like the show was so dumb, like look at his muscle. They're non-existent wow.
He's li the, even the suit it's like, so campy and corny,
but it was that way on purpose. Like when you punch guys,
you'd see like a bam in front of the screen. Do you remember Batman?
You're too young.
Yeah. Did you watch it at all? I would like play on the adults.
[Inaudible] Batman. Yeah, it was so, so corny.
Jeez. It was so campy and corny, but that's what it was.
And then when they went to Michael Keaton, like the movie was very different.
Like it was like brooding. And then when you get to Keith Heath ledger,
when he's ledgers playing Batman, he was the joke. Excuse me. The joker.
When he was playing the joker against Batman, rather you're getting this, uh,
like violent,
weird sort of character that is interacting with
Batman and taken over the city. There's half face,
literally half his face is seared off.
Incredible. Hans Zimmer. Stepped it up on that one too.
The music with the fleas. Wow.
Wow. Who is he supposed to be with me? Yeah. It's Mr. Freeze. That's the name?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Those are terrible. That was the Clooney one, right? Yes.
That was like, let's get as many famous people as we can in a movie.
Let's just throw as much against the walls. We can see what sticks there.
Actually. Jim Carrey. Wasn't Michelle Pfeiffer in that too.
Yeah, she was pleased. No,
that was the one before she was in the Michael Keaton.
One where she was a fat cat woman member.
Is that George Clooney? Yes, he looks good. Mostly good Batman. It's weird.
He's got it. They totally redid the, the suit, like the game, some fake abs
fake.
It's very odd catch new of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.